i'm good to go today's topic is hideism
hideism refers to the discrimination of
people based on height and in the dating
sphere
it's fairly uncommon for men to care
about a woman's height
one because we tend to be taller than
ladies on average but secondly
we just we don't give a [ __ ] honestly
if you're attractive or on board that's
the only thing that matters but for
ladies
height tends to be a more important
criteria i decided to go out
and ask some ladies if they thought
height was important i'd say it's pretty
important i would need someone that was
taller than me
i say it's not important but i've also
never dated a guy shorter than me i just
don't want him to be smaller than me
yeah over my head
[Applause]
when asked women why they ruled out
short men as potential life partners or
love interests in favor of taller men
these are the reasons ladies gave me the
fact that they could like pick you up
more easily than someone who's like say
the same height as you
ok
soon as i just heels because if i wear
heels he'll be i would be much taller so
i'll have to look down on him
i think that people will rationalize
anything i think that
traditionally speaking height is an
indicator of
good genetic quality and status
and people don't like to say that
outwardly so they say like
well yeah it's because of heels but like
how frequently are you going to find
yourself in a situation where you're
wearing heels
the main reason i got was heels i don't
want to be walking around with a dude
and
i got my heels on and people see him and
me and they think he's my little brother
that's kind of
ill fair enough i'm not going to judge
height is one of your dating criterias
and you need to know
cool but now when ladies come up to me
and they ask me abba
how tall are you i tend to respond with
how much do you weigh
and all of a sudden i'm the villain like
i did something wrong
so i asked girls if it was okay to ask
women about their waist size
no because that shouldn't really matter
no i don't think so
no i don't know did you not just say
that a man's gotta be over a certain
height or you'll feel like he's your
little brother and that's gross
well for me a woman's gotta be under a
certain weight or i'm gonna be worried
that they're gonna look at her
and think she ate her little brother
it's shallow isn't it
so why is it okay when you guys do it
based off height but when we mention
wait all of a sudden we're the demons
um actually i guess that is a little bit
a little bit like
she [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and the funny thing is it would make way
more sense for me to judge someone based
off their weight
than it would their height because
weight is based off your day-to-day
decisions
your dietary intake height is genetic
lottery you come out the womb and the
verdict is out it's
[ __ ] you're gonna be short for life
we've made it openly acceptable to mock
short people
yeah we we do it's open season we do
whatever the [ __ ] we want i just
it's excessive man i've been online and
read some stuff i'm like god damn
you [ __ ] are ruthless and i just
it's it's not necessary you know and i'm
not even mad at ladies for judging men
based off hype because i have my own
form of hideism right
i just call it uh uh tidism right i just
tidism is beautiful i love the
i don't just just bite the left titty
lap
no no okay the goal of the video is not
to say that we should hike shame or fat
shame or do any of that stuff
if you don't want to date someone
because they're short that's perfectly
fine
the only thing i'm getting at is whether
it's your height
or my requirement for titties it's all
shallow
you know so if you feel brazen enough to
make a big deal about my height
don't be surprised if i start asking
questions about your
waist size your ass size or how much
your titty meat weighs
that's all i'm saying pow
problem
foreign